quand j'étais petit aux confins de la
galaxie
j'ai entendu des histoires au sujet d'un
homme capable de prédire l'avenir
son histoire est restés obscurs pour moi
pendant bien des années
jusqu'à ce que cette histoire devienne
la mienne
jusqu'à ce qu'elle devienne la seule
histoire
vous connaissez mes travaux la
psychohistoire tu réellement tous les
mathématiciens ont lu votre théorie ce
n'est pas juste une théorie
c'est le destin de toute l'humanité
représentés par des chiffres et lempire
n'aimera guerre l'avenir que je préside
notre histoire est rempli de charlatans
et le faux prophète
tu anglais
nous pourrions le supprimer mais
qu'adviendra-t-il de ses idées les
martyrs ont tendance à laisser une trace
derrière
ces calculs sont exacts l' empire est à
l'agonie
l'ordre laissera place au chaos
le sort de milliers de monde sera réduit
à l'état de poussière
tout changement est effrayant surtout
pour les gens qui sont au pouvoir
mais nous pouvons amortir la chute
c'est quoi votre plan
après la chute lorsque la civilisation
renaîtra de ses cendres
[Musique]
les générations futures auront un socle
sur lequel tout reconstruire une
fondation
notre rôle est de préserver chacun des
trésors les plus essentiels de toute la
galaxie
ce qui restera dans les mémoires
tombera dans l'oubli
nous sommes maintenant aux portes
d'une crise
c'est ça le plan
il est trop tard pour faire demi tour
[Musique]